je reviens et bien entendu sur le sujet
de ce weekend à Sainte-Souline où nous
avons vécu un weekend terrible dans les
deux selles dans mon département et de
je tiens associer mon collègue gilba
Favreau ici présent comme vous l'avez
évoqué durant deux jours cette commune
de 350 habitants a vu des faire aller
près de 4000 personnes participant à une
manifestation interdite par la
préfecture contestant la réalisation du
réserve de substitution
malheureusement comme cela a été
prévisible et ressenti environ 400
extrémistes violents étaient associés à
cette manifestation
manifestation cochinez également par
leur présence par des élus de la
République qui appelle aujourd'hui elle
est désobéissance civique nous avons
vécu des scènes de violence inouïe et
comme vous l'avez fait madame le Premier
ministre je tiens également à celluler
l'engagement des forces de l'ordre à
apporter tout mon soutien aux personnes
blessées et à féliciter la préfète des
Deux-Sèvres
ce projet de réserve contestés par les
manifestants comme vous l'avez dit était
finalement validé par l'ensemble des
acteurs l'État le monde à l'école les
associations environnementales les îles
locaux ce projet est toujours dit
financé et légalement autorisé malgré
cela cette manifestation a été
orchestrée au nom de l'écologie mais ce
n'est qu'un prétexte politique voulant
institut un système de violence et
d'anarchie depuis 24 heures aujourd'hui
Sainte-Souline a retrouvé un peu de
calme mais elle risque est évoqué par
les médias il n'y a pas de Z mais les
agriculteurs et les habitants qui ont
été harcelés et qui méritent tout notre
soutien aspira de la tranquillité
monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur
puisque ces questions étaient dédiées
face à ce type d'événements inquiétant
pour notre société quelles réponses
judiciaire qui réponses politiques
comment faire pour que demain à
Sainte-Souline comme partout en France
ou un projet d'aménagement et
démocratiquement autorisé nous puissions
le réaliser sereinement